SPEAKER: No, say that again.
Every year,
me and Dad film together.
SPEAKER:
Oh, yes! For your birthday.
Yeah, so that's what
we're just doing.
-Oh, so that's what
you were doing?
-Yeah.
(LAUGHS) That's nice.
That's really nice.
-Beautiful. Beautiful.
-Yeah.
♪ (LOVING MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
Today's my birthday!
Hi!
Hi. My name is Ella.
Test, test, test, test,
test, test, test!
Okay, let's start.
-Daddy! My eyes...
-JAY ROSENBLATT: What?
Now, we're gonna get
the questions out.
Did you add any stupid ones?
Okay.
JAY: What do you want to do
when you grow up?
Put on makeup and eat gum.
To be a good person,
but not be perfect.
JAY: What do you want to say
to your older self?
Let's talk about you and me
for a second.
Are you happy?
I do feel like things
are changing.
JAY: My question, this last one,
I thought we'd want
to talk about something deeper.
What would you like to say?
I want you to ask
another question, okay?
No. (CHUCKLES)